down to the pad I'm the discounter
critic blah blah blah I like reviewing
things that the design the grid is in
that pair we doing how lame is that
that's like every time I sing will are
get hit in the head by one that's like
every time I say boy I get hit in the
head by one
sorry that way we can clean up the world
so you can become it's okay all right
Ted Turner you and you messed up the
line yeah I did I mean look at this
thing are you chilly oh stop making
these god-awful cartoons that way you
eat huh
well I'll tell you how I feel about this
situation I mean I I'm fuckin pissed off
you know well I'll tell you how I feel
about the situation I'm totally pissed
off I mean who wants to be the kid with
heart I mean that start ass
well I'll tell you how I feel about the
situation I'm really pissed off I mean
what kind of kid wants to have heart it
sucks in this is bad
I hate it I can't believe it but I'll
tell her well I'll tell you how I feel
about the situation I'm very pissed off
because what kind of kid wants to have
heart I mean I can't believe it it sucks
ass Jesus fuck people bringing people
together and bring you doesn't make you
toys bring you toys fuck people bringing
people together doesn't make your toys
it doesn't or it doesn't sell your toys
attract people bringing people together
and sell toys it just makes you a pussy
I am a pussy pussy fuck people people as
fuck people bringing people together
doesn't help you sort of you black
people black people black people black
people bringing people together doesn't
excel Turner bringing people together
doesn't help you sell toys bringing
people together does not help you sell
toys bringing people together does not
help you sell toys I'm lacking just
saying this fucking because I'm Indian
it's all Ted Turner's plan to keep : o
me do it again because I'm Indian
forgive me
because I'm Indian the fucking cards
because I'm Indian it's all dead
remember this fucking line it's one line
of camera because I'm in the end it's
all Ted Turner's plans to keep the
Indian man down
fucking cocksucker it just makes you a
pussy pussy pussy pussy a pudding a
pussy pussy pussy pussy pussy pussy
pussy pussy Jesus